[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link thank you for joining us once
again this week at the roundtable of dim
lighting covered in an increasingly
large number of signatures Hannah Hart
is the latest signature she is our guest
this week the amazing heart oh she she
got into some really good stuff great
candy conversation talked about the
extraordinary circumstances of her birth
and then the extraordinary life that she
had growing up in a home with a dad it
was a preacher and Jehovah's Witness
situation and then what it's like to
having been open about her sexuality on
her YouTube channel oh yeah it was like
there's it's got into conversation got
into everything that you want to get
into with the hannah harto but these
these signatures that that are
populating the round table of dim
lighting in this it made me think about
how everyone has this decision that they
make of how they're going to sign their
name and it made us think about another
story that we've been wanting to tell
you about signatures on our poster first
of all we're selling a poster now I'm
not am I gonna turn this into a store
opportunity well you you always you
always because the merch good mythical
morning poster isn't is now available on
our dftba store site all of these
posters are signed previous to that we
were selling and I think they're still
yeah there are still some mythical show
posters that are signed limited-edition
mythical show there will be no more of
those ever printed we sign them rhett
and Link right there with our silver
sharpie and you can buy it so anyway we
sold these and after they went they they
got shipped out after the first batch
was shipped out we we got a letter not a
letter we got a message and email and
you and I like to call them when they
comment when the letters come over the e
I call them emails and link why don't
you read this email we can tell you who
it's from but I pulled up the email and
I'm gonna read it verbatim from start to
finish
here we go my son recently purchased a
mythical show poster from dftba records
he is 14 years old and used his
hard-earned money to make the purchase
he was very excited to be getting a
poster quote signed in all capital
letters by both rhett and Link since he
is a big fan of the mythical show on
YouTube upon receipt of the poster the
first thing he noticed was that both
names are written in exactly the same
handwriting and neither person used
their last name o both first names only
written in silver paint marker exactly
the same size and exactly the same
location on the poster and the ampersand
quote ampersand symbol sign was used
between the names Rhett ampersand link
right why would two people use the
ampersand sign when signing both their
names
it also looks as if rhett and Link quote
were written by a teenager this is what
he noticed his fourteen-year-old son I
have a friend who does handwriting
analysis for our local police department
he took a quick look at the poster and
agreed that neither name was probably
authentic and both were unquestionably
written by the same hand unquestionably
he also agreed that any time a quote
celebrity autographs anything unless
they are Prince Madonna or Cher they
would probably use their last name as
well then he quotes from Wikipedia quote
rhett and Link is the comedy filmmaking
Musical and advertising duo of rhett
james mclaughlin and Charles Lincoln
link Neil end quote
both are 30 something guys neither is
Madonna Prince or Cher that's true
hopefully I'm thinking a last name is an
order here okay obviously you can see
where this is going this is still his
email if your purpose is to rip off
their target audience
teenage boys then you are clearly
successful
since most folks might not have picked
up on the signatures and would be happy
to have the poster but if you were truly
concerned about actually selling what
you advertised then I think reparations
are in order he will gladly return the
pathetically signed poster for an
authentic one thank you for your
consideration in this matter and then he
gives his mailing address we will not
give that or his name okay now when I
first read this email I was a little
upset because if you have if you know us
at all if you've listened or watched
anything that we've ever done and you
know a little bit about the kind of
people we are you probably know that
this is not the kind of thing that we
would do we would not hire a teenager to
sign our names on a poster but let me
tell you after signing one thousand of
these and then boxing them back on it's
not about them to your house and letting
you unbox them and sign your name and
the ampersand either around mine or
before mine to anticipate where I'm
gonna write it with my own hand right
and then you boxing it up and we send it
to dftba to ship them out maybe we
should hire a teenager it certainly
seemed maybe we should i source this
whole thing we should outsource the
whole thing well ok so ok
for whatever reason probably because my
last name is McGlothlin very early on we
all pay signed Rhett link because that's
who we are
well you know it's is rhettandlink you
don't call us rhett mclaughlin and link
neal so we always sign ourselves sign
her name's rhett and Link and we always
use the ampersand and like link said if
I if I sign it first I do the ampersand
and if link signs at first he doesn't
hamper say and and our signatures don't
look like they both been written by the
same T name mine's in cursive and yours
is in print which is so anyway who is
this handwriting expert expert well he
should lose his job first of all so
anyway it was one of those situations
where your mantilla cused of things that
make me so they're making me out to be
something that I'm not and the thing
that really struck me is how positive
beyond a shadow of a doubt this dad was
in fact he had a thought he had a belief
he had a perspective
then every single thing about the world
that he was observing in relation to
this poster in his mind confirmed his
suspicions that we were swindlers that
we were hiring a teenager to deceive his
son and to get $20 out of his son's
pocket and you know it's not fun to be
accused of something like that so what I
did is I wrote what I'm going to confess
was a pretty smartass response and I can
I read part of it I have it all right
hello first name of father who wrote the
email
tell your son thanks for ordering a
poster period return that was your first
paragraph huh second paragraph is much
longer
we appreciate your desire to protect
your son against being taken advantage
of but we were frankly taken aback at
your level of certainty that we have
been fraudulent we're sorry if you feel
that our process for signing things
first names only with an ampersand is
unacceptable but that is the way we've
always ought agraphia should just keep
reading go ahead since we've known since
we're known publicly and professionally
as quote ret ampersand link this is what
we sign our lives can testify to the
fact that we each sat alone in our
respective dining room tables and signed
hundreds of posters over the many hours
with our quote half and instill the
posters up and exchanged them so the
other could sign his quote other half
we're also a bit concerned about the
opportunity the aptitude of your friend
who specializes in handwriting analysis
and worried that he might be causing
your local police department to
wrongfully convicts um one considering
that our signatures are clearly
different mine ret susan curse if all
links is in print we couldn't duplicate
one another signatures if we try but
most importantly we think it would be
wise to be slow
you got a typo in your email you said we
think it would be wise to be slow to be
oh I'm sorry I just can't read it right
let me try this one more time
but most importantly we think it will be
wise to be slow to be so accusatory in
the future your absolute unquestioning
perspective that we had attempted to
scam our audience is more than a little
insulting I would hope that after
watching our videos for any length of
time your son has learned that we are
not the kind of guys who would ever
consider doing something so insidious is
selling fake sign
stirrers that being said we would gladly
ship you a poster sign with our full
names signed on the poster at a location
of your choosing thanks again for your
support of internet tainment Rhett
ampersand link so then we send him
another poster signed Rhett James
McLaughlin in Charles Lincoln link Neal
the third so this guy and his son have
one of the only play only poster ever
that was signed in full names all right
let's get to Hannah Hart we had a great
conversation like I said so
let's delay no more give a few stats
yeah you know her from youtube.com slash
my heart oh where she has just under
eight hundred thousand subscribers and
is known best for her weekly show my
drunk kitchen she's also the 2013
Streamy winner for best female
performance in a comedy and she is a
nice woman as you will find out in a
second she was also in our Christmas
sweats music video alongside grace
ladies and gentlemen our convo with
Hannah Hart speak on breathing air we
discuss the topics open breathing air is
what you want to call our podcast
I think breathing air is like a it's a
it's pretty good radio voice thing to
say now you did know you were on an
email chain from a couple of weeks ago
we were trying to get you on the show
and well several weeks ago before we had
named the show mm-hm and our producer
Stevie mm-hmm was just being funny in
her email and she said yeah we're
calling it Oprah raw remember that loved
Oprah raw and and then when we finally
changed it your biscuits via email you
expressed disappointment that it wasn't
called Oprah raw I think that's natural
really his Oprah we're all taken or does
that supposed to mean something I found
the gross to me I mean if I'm gonna dine
on Oprah
I'd prefer her I think I met unfiltered
real yeah Oprah raw yeah Oprah raw I had
nothing to do with cannibalism no
as open to interpretation is what it
seems to me here's what we'll do for you
10 today's episode this week's episode
is it is still a near biscuit mm-hmm but
it is there's a subtitle and it is Oprah
raw Oprah raw edition we call it
breathing air I ain't gonna go breathing
air with Oprah raw but people are gonna
think that Oprah's gonna be here and I'm
just saying she's not a manager she's a
big fan she's a big fan of you talked
about it in O Magazine and I'm a member
in a podcast section I think she's just
referring to putting a pair of nice warm
biscuits on your ear okay yeah that
happens it's delicious now Hannah we've
met in person the first time at a coffee
shop second time we met you mean was
yeah funny way to meet but we totally
did it was an arranged meeting it was
like a first it was like a blind date
really yeah yeah it went well I thought
so yeah that's that coffee shop now
listen great yeah it's a nice collision
the coffee shop was bricks and scones
yes come here all right scone scone
biscuits and I remember after you know
we had a great conversation and I
remember you know linking our on our way
home and discussing people that we have
just met as we often do because we're
pretty much always together mm-hmm
and we were both like I like that Hannah
Hart now Oh Hannah Hart he's a nice
person
nice woman you guys it's really nice
he's a nice woman
you know it's so funny you say that
because when I went away when I drove
away from our first meeting that first
impression first impression you do it
straight I was talking to myself by
myself allowed as long as want to do my
and I said you know Hannah I that
rhettandlink thumbs guys were yeah
mm-hmm because I was talking to myself
and I had no visual or verbal feedback
to go off of
you didn't say nice men I was hoping you
liked those were nice men what what she
just said that she said was them's guys
wow you know and it kind of fizzled out
yeah sometimes those car talks get real
weird ones a brick and ones a scone no
come on you got to give it you got to
give us the real first impressions yeah
hmm well it can't be like what he's tall
he's an honest talk and blanka's really
great hair they both got great hair hey
I was like they were lovely good
definitely not from California yeah
because you guys had a slower cadence
yeah you guys you guys like to take your
time telling a story and it's it's
delicious it's a great way to speak it's
just a function of brain power yeah
we're a little slow that's all it is
fully charged
yeah but when we met actually the show
the long-form show guys we're just
thinking you guys were just starting and
thinking about that yeah that's over now
mm-hmm we've graffiti together yeah but
the second time that we met in person
was the Christmas sweat suit I'm pretty
sure that was our second meeting
yeah and that was wonderful and that was
a phenomenal shoe I wear those Christmas
sweats grace told us we heard about this
yeah I do
I'm disappointing you I have them on I
mean it's not that cool yet are you
sleeping those asleep in those exact
sweatpants really yeah I mean like I
will I didn't use a green pair I was
gonna say I'll text you guys a picture
later tonight and then I just stopped
myself yeah you did yeah that's actually
a picture I mean my sweat yeah I have a
picture of me and my sweat you have both
green and red no I just have the red
small pants in a box yeah we've got the
greens and when I can be your parting
gift from here today on ear biscuits Wow
Wow it was a great treat though great
video yeah yeah I really I really
enjoyed we should sequel Isaac got on
Good Morning America I know how funny is
that oh you've made it they're like
who's that from p1 well I think because
the picture that they we decided to use
as the thumbnail you were wearing the
extra large this ones which were my
sweats that actually fit me mm-hmm
do you still wear this what we keep him
packaged you know I'd like to separate
the
assuming from the actual wardrobe how do
you feel like your real life and your
creative life bleed together far too
often it's really just a tax issue my
CPA told me that you know you can't wear
those costumes you gotta kiss sweats in
a box you can't you can't write them off
if you what if you wear them my CPA told
me to do whatever I want
everything that's probably more fun
mm-hmm it is we put you wear that shirt
in the video expense it done you can't
do that I know technically but you know
the news anchors can't even expense
their suits they have to buy their own
by their own seriously no way yeah yeah
crazy
did you see how the only reason I'm not
a news anchor wait um how did you find
out that my brother told me this and how
he knows I don't know mmm I think he has
a business degree he does have a
business degree from a reputable
institution that's like business 101
mm-hmm it's like the extra credit
question on the first quiz of business
101 in a news anchor expense his suit
right it sounds like business really
suits him oh wow
all right so take us back gets back to
your birth is the whole story where was
it when was it I was born November 2nd
1986 and it was in the bay area of
California on the west coast of America
on the planet Earth which is the third
planet in our solar system within the
Milky Way is a show about that yeah also
a song Joe Diffie song I don't the
country country-western tune no prob
mmm-hmm he also sang a song called prop
me up beside the jukebox when I died
yeah so he wants to be like taxidermied
he does Admiral Admiral
yeah yeah I propped up like this is
sergeant thing to want to do we may area
various likes San Francisco ish yes in
the Bay Area yeah it was great grow up
in California I went to school at
Berkeley I studied Japanese literature
and you gotta move slower than that we
want to talk about like kindergarten you
know yeah this is what and your biscuit
it's all about you know how did
we're like spinning fish during a
college here in the delivery's I'm sorry
I should have explained I came out of
the womb and went to college but it was
for baby Hannah no um I let me think
okay back to birth oh I was born with a
double nuchal cord you guys know what
that is yeah we have kids double nuchal
cord it's where the umbilical cord is
wrapped twice around your neck I was
like an so you could have died yeah but
so the doctor the doctor had to go in
and cut the cord within my mother's
buddy
and then I came out so he took up this
pair of scissors inside of your mom and
cut the cord so I could get get born cuz
I like you know feet-first cord neck
came out blue I mean yeah but I'm a
fighter
slash I don't know what baby Hannah was
like so there are extraordinary
circumstances in your birth so is that
the type of thing that growing up
whenever something would happen be it
good or bad that or your mom or dad
would hearken back to you know you're
you're a miracle baby
yeah miracle baby mm-hmm they would say
that not so much however I would say
that in my head to myself I'm a miracle
baby
I would just have a miracle just wake up
morning I was born choking mm-hmm I was
born choking around yep yep yep
but they did your parents didn't say
that because they mean they could say
that they could they could have but I
don't know I don't think it really
occurred to them okay that's fair yeah
okay and what what kind of house were
you born into parents together siblings
well I was born
into a my parents are divorced before I
was born I had one older sister have you
know she's alive
and yes you our mom raised us for a long
while and then she got remarried and had
another baby that's my baby sister who I
love very very much and yeah there was a
good time
so you grew up with just your mom and
then a stepdad at some point
mhm mm-hmm when did the stepdad come in
I guess I was like seven there about hey
this is all and this is all in the Bay
Area yeah I never moved around and
raised born and raised in the Bay Area
never moved around just kind of like
hung out a lot what'd your mom do she
worked nights audio-visual recording
thing where she would transcribe news
stories so she would go in from like 10
p.m. to like 5:00 a.m. and do
transcriptions so she would listen to
she would just watch Neos mm-hmm and
then just write out everything they said
and then she would come home and be like
you'll never believe what happened I
hate the news to this day why don't
people tell good news like it's not
relevant to just hear there was like a
stabbing in the park like what can we
benefit from by knowing that well if you
hang on long enough they do like
something that's light hearted towards
the end well it's you could also know
not to go to that Park that's true you
know if you don't want to get stabbed
don't go to that I just wish there was a
website that was like good news calm
like or like every news story was like
we have that reserved no net we have org
no we don't I beg of actually hmm oh no
it's not gov since the shutdown no
that's right yeah can't go I can't even
go online really okay so she would watch
that it's so when you're watching the
news and you see the closed captions
happening they're happening live and
someone like your mom is making no no no
it's more like it was just a
transcription service you know so it's
like news organizations I imagine and
remember my understanding of this is
that four year olds understanding like I
have no idea I believe what the service
was was to give the studios
transcriptions of the shows or the new
for closed captioning I mean there's all
types of reason yeah when we did our
show and I have see yeah they had people
who would I can't run with their
positions were but they would type out
everything that was said yeah and then
they could do a paper cut meaning they
could look at what was written down and
they could say edit it this way based oh
we need him to we need him to say this
to manipulate the reality of the
situation that would happen a few times
even on our show and or we need to tell
this story we need someone to say this
so they could search for it and find it
instead of just scrubbing through a
whole bunch of footage so I would
imagine there's you know you could be it
could save the world you never know
there's intelligence in that kind of
stuff I love I love that perspective no
is your mom still Deschutes old-type no
now she's unemployed well because we
could use somebody to do this for your
biscuits oh that's where I was good now
I mean there's a lot of talking going on
and somebody needs to be writing it down
don't you think link I mean I'm never
occurred to me yeah I remember being
confused about my dad's job mm-hmm we
lived out here in California when I was
a kid mm-hmm and at the time Pat Sajak
was a weatherman before Wheel of Fortune
or any suits free suits oh yeah mm-hmm
meteor rock meteorological loophole he
and BS about something that important
here I gotta call you out okay yeah I
remember distinctly watching Pat Sajak
deliver the weather one day and being
100% convinced that it was my father
well what he looks nothing like ed did
you feel it in your heart I was like
four years old I remember thinking mom
actually sing mom dad's on television
dad doing the weather and I was totally
convinced that it was somebody was Pat
Sajak
but maybe Pat Sajak was your mom like
he's not the father you have yeah she
got this really guilty look yeah well
that might explain a lot yeah all right
that's a jack is my dad I want to look
at a picture of Pat Sajak so bad right
now
he's a very short man which makes this
highly unlikely right that's true okay
so in your sisters how much younger than
you I have two sisters I'm an old
three years older than me and a younger
one who is 11 years younger than me okay
so when you're a kid it was you and your
older sister and your mom mm-hmm three
women against the world
so I mean wait tell us about that um
well I really liked books a lot I think
that like you know when you have a
single mom you don't really like got a
lot to do so fortunately though she the
house was like filled with books so I
would read a lot of books would you
transcribe them right I transcribe I
know I just read them like she had like
a lot of Encyclopedia Britannica's do
you murmur when they would smell like
the phone you didn't buy the Shelf with
him yeah seriously really yeah when you
buy that many books you got to buy the
shelter they would throw that in for
likes to sweeten the deal
no way well if he knew how to negotiate
oh so you would read all the you would
read the encyclopedia but your mind your
mom worked nicer what she liked sleeping
during the day was it like no she was
out usually she spent a lot of time out
but I would I am sure a reading yeah I
like to read I like to read a lot I also
like to yep bookworm and I also like to
take a lot of walks I like to like walk
around the neighborhood like just like
make up adventures we're talking great
school right yeah okay yeah you know
just like that sort of thing one time me
and my friends climb to the roof of the
elementary school and we threw rocks at
cars you're kidding me
that were driving by and only as an
adult do I realize how truly dangerous
and stupid that was but at the time I
was like this is fun but no no that's
bad one time we're going to stop you
there because we did exactly the same
thing and in fact we've told this story
on good mythical morning but no the last
time I was spanked spanked I think you
were 13 I was 14 14 now listen I wasn't
spanked I was made a lot as like a young
kid and it became very intermitted
but then I was 14 I had your from a tall
guy I were 14 when I was 14 I was 6 foot
4
my dad was 5-9 remember he looks like
pass agent it's convenient because they
all I had to do is tell you to bend over
the back of the couch we spend you and
Lincoln I got call it throwing rocks at
cars on top of the business school long
story
we got caught by Leonard Johnson at the
business school that jerk who told your
brother about the suits he told the
security Campbell security about that
who told my dad and then my dad called
me in there and he's like so what'd you
do today he didn't even have you cut a
switch or anything no belt and he was
like now is you know we don't do this
anymore but I have no choice
and right there on the keister you know
I never threw rocks at cars again hmm I
think for the record he probably did
have a choice oh sorry guys that you can
take that might be Pat Sajak I mean just
going to be like muscle okay so you you
I mean it's a common thing apparently
lots of kids to do it throw rocks at
cars everybody's have that experience
yeah but did you get punished no no not
really I felt guilty I felt terrible we
one of the rocks went through a window
at the school when school started again
and remember this is this was second
grade first first or second second grade
maybe oh you weren't for time um no no
but uh that's something I'll never
forget
no did you get spanked did you get in
trouble uh yeah I mean but not for stuff
like that just other things oh you got
spanked as a child too yeah but yeah
yeah you know but so I remember though I
felt so bad about throwing the rock
through the window or the rock hitting
the window that when school started
everybody's like oh my god Rock window
Ella I remember going to my teacher and
just being like it was me and she was
like no it wasn't nothing it was me I
did it I did it over the weekend I live
down the block Oh guys she was like
Hannah please like it wasn't you I
appreciate you trying to cover for your
friend
well but I know it wasn't you I just
know you and I was like
this is the worst feeling in the world I
mean like how do you go like anyway so
you confessed and it was rejected that
can't be you it's not you and then
you're like wait Who am I so you had a
reputation as being a good kid yeah and
you were a kid that would you felt
guilty and you would confess something
like that oh I was a good I had a good
good heart so that kid that
characterized your your youth yeah it
wasn't one of rebellion and testing the
limits definitely not a rebellious child
I was definitely a you know I mean like
I would like help out the janitor after
school and stuff like I just wanted to
like do stuff I just like people I like
I really like I just really like being
with people you know I think people are
interesting hmm you know did you help
the janitor put the sawdust on the vomit
from kids puking they did that all the
time in our school yeah sawdust that's
that's - every other day there would be
a pilot sawdust out there you sit on you
were 14 when last time you puke mr. Leon
mr. Leon was our janitor and he would
sawdust all kinds of stuff but
especially vomit well I mean why don't
he just clean it up poor Miss Hannigan
only had one hand and we never helped
him out you make me feel bad I've never
helped him clean up vomit the guy I had
one hand he had two hands when we
started at school remember he you know
what happened are you cereal yes do you
don't know the story about mr. Leon mr.
Leon clean was vomit no mr. Leon woods
in the wood chipper he was changing the
bulbs the footlights
on the oh no on the school stage in the
auditorium he was changing the
footlights and one broke or one was hot
or something he got burned it was a very
mild thing he did not get it checked out
it got infected and they cut his hand
off this was like fifth grade man
because we had a two-handed janitor and
then he became a one-handed janitor it
he never slowed down by the way that
seems like a little rash well you mean
it was an overreaction
no it was a bad infection it was like he
didn't get it kids if you get an
infection
get it taken care of mm-hmm that's
immoral that story if you vomit throw
sawdust on it I can't find any it turns
out when people tear you
tell you to air out a wound don't this
is covered it'll heal fast that's right
we've established this that recently
yeah I told him I told him not to wear
the band-aid and turns out he's right
look at it now we're good to go yeah all
right scars kind of cool like when stuff
scars you like that's cool
I like that's cool I don't see any scars
on you I got I have one right here in my
hand I got one on my knee I don't want
in this ear in the ear mm-hmm I just ran
into a table and I was really little
just like the corner of a table I was
just so excited I was also very excited
this kid I'm still very excited about
and I just hit the corner it was the
first time I ever got stitches and I
totally fainted wonder-percent well they
just have thought of it makes me want to
faint if you how awful oh yeah an ear
wound any room here biscuits I don't
know biscuit I'm not interested in that
so give us some more formidable
formidable I don't know what the right
word is relative that's what formative
points in your in your life we're
talking like the grade school middle
school high school years you know we're
still pretty Berkeley here oh yeah well
my dad is a preacher and we saw him your
real dad or your stepdad I real dad
that's okay so your mom and your dad
they divorced before you were born
mm-hmm and he's a preacher what type of
preacher we talking drove is witness
Jehovah's Witness mm-hmm Wow mm-hmm so
he doesn't celebrate birthdays mm-hmm
why not I don't I don't the idea made a
comment on a good mythical morning and
then I got reprimanded by people who
said I should know and so I school me
well from what I recall as the idea is
that it's kind of like I always was very
confused by this because I was like if
we were God's creatures or as God's
creatures isn't the celebration of the
birth one of the most sacred things but
John the Baptist got his head cut off as
a birthday present so the witnesses have
taken that to be like celebration of
birthdays is bad
III follow the logic there you know I
mean you know everybody's got their
thing just be good just be nice people
practice whatever religion you know what
was your relationship like with your dad
did you have visitation growing
what was the arrangement yeah we had
visitation I saw him I guess like four
days we saw him like four days a month
in two weeks in summer and he I know it
was always like it was so the opposite
of what the right regular life because
it was like you know get you know
getting dresses get really clean like go
to you know like six church things a
weekend now we're going door to door and
then afterward on growing door to door
we're gonna go to the church barbecue
and after we're done doing that we're
gonna go it's actually not called the
church it's called the kingdom hall and
then our windows there's a few windows
yeah there's small very small exactly
it's called the kingdom hall not a
church and they're called meetings not
services okay so this is I mean this
being in a Jehovah's Witness family this
is a is quite a commitment there's
there's a this is big part of your life
so I would assume that at that time your
your mom was also a part of this or was
she just kind of saying okay well your
dad's doing this and we're kind of just
gonna kind of ride along yeah I mean
honestly I mean I was never a Jehovah's
Witness I mean I was just like my dad
and so when he said when he left was
your mom like okay we're not gonna do
that anymore let's not go to the kingdom
hall anymore yeah she is just you know
very theological she believes in like
you know history and like all religion
and spirituality and Christianity and
she's got a lot of different beliefs
very wide variety but um yeah you know I
got no problem with jovis witnesses you
know every religion teaches own my only
logic is like just be like nice to each
other you know just like I think that
that's what really matters
that's what Jesus would want what was
your observation I mean did you go to a
church with your mom what was your
observation visiting your dad and I
guess having a label of Jehovah's
Witness and being an outsider that you
not being at home as witness what was
your observation there and then growing
up with your mom how you were raised
there um it just seemed so different you
know it just seems so and obviously you
know this is nothing to do with the
religion at large but like it just felt
very superficial you know what I mean
like my dad and his stepmom
were them and it was very like Stepford
feeling when we would go and visit them
and like it was just a very interesting
juxtaposition like they had everything
and like oh they had like food and
everything was like clean and yada yada
yada but it didn't feel like home
whereas like home felt like you know
sure it wasn't perfect but it was real I
guess in a weird way yeah I mean I guess
I mean I grew up as a young kid I didn't
grow up my dad so I had visitation with
my dad I remember every other weekend
for a while and I mean religion wasn't
that different between my mom and my dad
they both were church-going Christian
people but I mean that I can certainly
relate to that part about even not
feeling like oh this is going to see my
dad it wasn't home it was a different
thing when you're that young it's just
something you just kind of plug into and
and it would just be like I just
remember feeling so bummed out if like a
friend was having a birthday party one
weekend I like there was an opportunity
to like see a movie or like go on a
school trip and like that opportunity
came available but it was a dad weekend
I was like right you know which is like
you know not no fault of his but I was
always I just never wanted to go and
there was a lot of sounds like there was
a lot of religious obligations every
time you were there we got we got a
dress this way we got to go here we got
to do this this is my waking up a job
5:30 6:00 a.m. we're gonna go to this
thing like a brutal just like there's a
they have thing called the district
Convention which is like 12 hours of
service and it happens like one or two
weekends a year and I remember if we had
a dad visit on the district convention I
was like I would lay awake for like
weeks knowing that it was coming it was
it's brutal imagine being a kid and I
now know why this was so like just so
hard like having to go for me as a kid
and sit still and just be preached at
for 12 hours not be able I couldn't
doodle
I couldn't even write my own like
stories I had to sit and literally just
sit and listen and follow along and book
it was the most pain like just it was
hell
so hard you just couldn't sit there and
like snicker at each other like Lincoln
I did in the balcony at our our little
church no snickering had no falling
asleep so you know that feeling where
you're so under stimulated that you're
just like you're like literally just
pulling your eyes up to stay awake no
snickering no falling asleep no doing
something else like no coloring no
drawing no anything just listen and it
was oh and that was until what age 17
okay see you and your sister a little
bit older did that did that draw the two
of you closer kind of oh yeah I know my
big sister Knight you know wait we're
good we're solid yeah it was just like
just I just would never do that to any
any child like I barely believe in
education the way we do it I'm like kids
are gonna get curious about things at
different times in their life like maybe
this kid wants to learn math right now
great let them learn math later them
want to learn this you know like I think
that we should really just like have
structure but not control it's like okay
we're gonna learn from 8:00 a.m. to 3:00
p.m. but what you learn what you're
curious about is entirely up to you you
know but you are gonna be like
progressing in some way you know right
that so did you have a reaction that
even if that is you are like I'm gonna
Chuck this whole religious thing no I
mean like the word you know I think
fortunately like my mom's opinion and
openness I guess really saved my view of
spirituality and view of people's
relationships with God you know I think
that if I only had the Jehovah's Witness
perspective I would 100% be like forget
that but because I also had my mom who's
like well Judaism believes this Buddhism
believes this you know let's watch
history of the Bible like oh I got this
great documentary from the library like
let's watch this like just a very like
rich multicultural experience with
spirituality and God and what people
believe so that made me feel connected
to that was that something that was
developing like you know as you were a
teenager you're in high school and
you're in this environment was it just
like I just don't know about this this
stuff that we're doing that seems like
rote seems like obligation were you kind
of beginning to think that this there's
got to be something other than this or
after he left and your mom having these
influences and these ideas all along all
along I mean I never he never I didn't
have no recollection of them being in
the same room you know okay so like they
were yeah like I really don't have any
memory of them being together but I like
prayed every night as a kid and I still
like I still take a moment before I eat
you know and before I go to sleep should
just be grateful because I think that
that's really important you know mm-hmm
like those are still patterns that like
I maintain so what was high school like
for you um high school was good I got my
first job which I liked I worked I
worked at ice cream shop oh yeah yeah in
a sample giver mm-hmm scooper sample
giver I called everybody sweetie officer
yeah yep yep baskin-robbins everyone it
was Preston's in Burlingame California
which is a locally like owned you know
small business family-owned business
public law and had been there forever
and it was great and I also worked at a
video store and that was great and those
are two classic jobs a classic job what
was your first teenaged job
it was cleaning out underneath houses oh
I cleaned out underneath houses a little
bit too when the construction people get
through building the house mm-hmm when
they get through they have used the
foundation of the house as a trash can
oh really they send a kid underneath
there to clean it all out and put
plastic under there and as I've already
established I'm a pretty big guy I was
already pretty big and I'm going there
houses worrying about snakes and like
cups with redneck tobacco juice in them
oh yeah that was my first job I think
that was my first that was the one of my
high school jobs yeah that's gross and I
wasn't working with ice cream that's for
sure
yeah it was expired and it was in a
little container underneath the house no
grass
yeah I loved it I would I would go back
to that right now and in an instant I'm
not surprised by that actually I see you
as somebody that would really enjoy just
like the routine order and the structure
of the order
yeah just going to level para nose hair
trimmers making sure it's all I had a I
had a riding lawnmower Hanna well I mean
you know I remember that you would I
have a memory of you riding a riding
lawnmower like down the road in
Lillington like from one house to
another is that is that true did it
happen
yeah I didn't I would drive the lawn
mower across Lillington across major
streets to go to houses that I had to
mow because that was easier than putting
it on a trailer and then driving I was
before I didn't have my license before a
lawn mower race did you pick up a lot of
chicks Mary Ellen where the ladies
around Lillington loved the guy with the
lawn mower I mean it were easy to keep
up where the girls could just jump a
sidewalk right next to you the whole
time that's a man with ambition they
could tell okay so keep it level
I scream saw in video store huh yeah I
scream and video store
I raised my little sister a bunch I was
a yearbook I did the yearbook and
newspaper publication okay hmm
I thought it was gonna be a journalist
or a teacher with the majority my life
and I pursued translation so you were
very plugged and very involved not with
the school I mean like I was I was
plugged in and involved into like you
know it was easy everybody knew me and
so it was easy to get in and get out of
what I wanted so it's like during
journalism of doing your book it was
he's like I could just walk into the
room I need this picture thanks guys bye
I mean like it was easy to take care of
and I would leave school and then I'll
go work mm-hmm
so you thought you wanted to be a
journalist at the time I did or a
teacher and when you decided to go to
Berkeley mm-hmm
was that to pursue that career um well I
went into Cal it's actually really funny
I first didn't plan on going to college
and then was encouraged by my guidance
counselor to go to college so I applied
to a bunch of schools in Berkeley was
like my reach school they were like well
you should apply to Berkeley you know
blah blah blah blah blah I got rejected
from every single school I applied to
except for Berkeley who sent a letter
and but California public school or
California public university they don't
do this asking for two letters of
recommendation and it was a 13 s a
question questionnaire
it was part of the Equal Opportunities
program and I did it and then I got into
Berkeley and I said what was your equal
opportunity well you're a white girl
yeah but I grew up in poverty and my mom
is schizophrenic okay so you left that
part up yeah it's a friend yeah so we
actually I got emancipated when I was
like 15 and my little sister went to
foster care
Wow yeah so there was a good chunk of
stuff that helped you know I had
terrible grades but great test results
terrible grades like I mean I wasn't
gonna homework my goodness so when you
said a few minutes ago that you raised
your little sister you literally meant
that yes your mom was diagnosed and I
mean can you tell us more about that how
did that happen yeah I mean it's kind of
like I want people like I think at some
point in my life I'd like to speak you
know at length about mental health
stigma with the illness like
schizophrenia
it's a psychosis so it's not like a
sociopath like illness which is like
kind of like you know people do bad
things but like a psychotic illness you
know as we describe people like oh that
guy's psychotic he's not actually
psychotic like that's a bad guy
psychotic means like voices images
hallucinations like multiple reality
like that's psychotic
you know um so yeah what was your
question you were raising you because
your mom was struggling with this
illness mm-hmm you had to kind of step
in and raise yours yes sir he was 11
years young what led up to that point I
mean what what does that mean exactly
does she have to go get treatment
somewhere how did that work you know
things would have been around I think
things would have been really different
if she had gotten treatment but now she
just gets panic just you know there's a
lot of people are unmedicated mentally
ill so she was in the house she was
working she was there but she wasn't
able to function yes mom she wasn't
really able to she wasn't able to do a
lot of things she wasn't able to do a
lot of jobs and she had like you know
she had she had a guy that came and like
helped out with like bills and stuff but
she just got worse so she got older you
know so it went from like you're quirky
and weird and everything seems weird but
guess that's cool like we're just
different and then as I got older and
when Maggie was born it's no sister it
was like wow we're not different like
something's wrong you know and I
remember being 11 and my mom telling my
sister and I that she got pregnant and I
remember being like you need to have an
abortion because we can't have a child
in this house like what are you gonna do
with a baby like how we like like how we
gonna have a baby then she had the baby
and that was like the best thing that
ever happened to me right yeah Maggie
would like totally saved my life i 100%
could become like that kid that like
does drugs and runs away from home and
like all that stuff but Maggie was just
smiling loving baby I mean you guys have
kids you know like all you have to do
for a babies love it and it's like loves
you back and then they get older and
then you you know more responsibilities
but like it was a good pure thing you
know how did your mom's illness kind of
manifest itself that I mean you you
would see it manifest herself at a point
where that's what you said when you
found out she was pregnant mm-hmm and
that brought you to a point where it
your life without Maggie could have gone
off the deep end is what you're saying
yeah I mean I honestly I think that the
point where everything changed was
probably when I was like 15 or 16 and my
sister my older sister I'd been like
peace I'm going to college and then you
know like I said it's a it's an illness
it gets worse with age I just what was
happening I don't you know just crazy
stuff so anyway I just didn't want
Maggie I just couldn't picture Maggie
being there alone and then like the
closer I got to 18 it was like well
either I'm just gonna like take her or
you know next time the cops come I'm not
gonna lie I'll be like actually things
are terrible you know so yeah so there's
a point in which you kind of you saw the
situation you saw what was happening and
you were like I've got to sort of take
control here I meant I'm gonna mess
emancipate myself I'm gonna give my
that's just her into foster care a
chance foster care by the way is a
really fascinating system and like
there's a lot of like deeply flawed
parts of it Maggie was in the state
foster care system for only like three
weeks before I had a good reputation you
know in my home town for a family
volunteer
to adopt her or take her in and then
later in life they adopted her and she's
been living there for the last I don't
know how old am I 26 how old was she at
the time for well yeah so yeah but I
mean it's you know there's a lot of
things that I want to do to help out
with this stuff like eventually it's
like there's so many things that you
could change to make things better and
it just turns out money's the only thing
you need so it's like I'd love to like
either advocate for or start a
foundation that kind of provides
services to those who do foster care and
I'm not talking about monetary services
because I don't think that in Kurt that
doesn't help that doesn't work because
then people are like give me kids so I
get checks but like services like you
know maybe they go and have their own
counseling you know or they go and have
their own job security training you know
I mean give these people skills and give
them like their shot at life so that
when they're fostering kids it's almost
like a shot for self-improvement right
so so your experience as going through
that has sort of giving you given you a
mission of sorts yeah and is it I mean
is there something that now that you are
the Hannah Hart that we all know and you
know the YouTube celebrity Hannah Hart
love sir have makeup on a face that's
right check out youtube.com slash
hardtail Halloween double-win tumblr you
said different things but you did not
like your title card everything's give
me a freeze RAM of a data card research
title good you see this as because
obviously part of your brand is sort of
you know with your recent tour a part of
your brand is sort of giving back to
people and bringing people together and
and that's very evident like I know that
you've done a lot of your gatherings it
like soup kitchens and volunteering for
people when did that become a part of
your like identity and your in your
brand well it didn't become a part of my
identity until I got security I guess
you know like it was like the channel
was doing well and I was successful and
like I could support like my loved ones
and then I just felt like entertainment
felt so hollow mmm so then it was like
wow like actually I'm
side of privilege now like I can give
back and I guess that's kind of what I
try and say when we were doing the
meetups and stuff like that and arguably
by the way like I'm not at all perfect
like I don't go to a soup kitchen every
week like I'm not you know I try and
like donate money but like you know I'm
not like tiny I'm not 100% on the time
all the time blah blah blah blah blah I
don't want to make myself out to be that
way cuz you know I'm human and blah but
I do think that some one way of looking
at donating charity volunteer work is to
think that it's not a guilt it's not an
obligation but it's more like a
privilege like you're lucky you're lucky
enough to do you're able to give back
yeah not like you're able so you should
like people push back against that so
hard but more like hey if you're sitting
at home depressed or if you're feeling
like your life is empty or bubble bubble
bubble blah like go outside for two
hours meet a bunch of strangers and like
sort cans or something it'll make you
feel good so if you need a selfish way
to justify something like a not guilt
way like a selfish way like go do it cuz
it's gonna make you feel good well when
we found out that you were doing your
meet-up said you know soup kitchens and
shelters and that kind of thing we
thought back to the fact that we across
the country and did a bunch of meetups
at rest stops
I don't like we broke up a lot of shady
activities you guys brought a lot of
positive energy into the rest stop not a
lot of positive energy and a rest stop
and for us it was really hard though to
get people to let us into the we went to
food banks and we went to like to soup
kitchens but went to a bunch of food
banks because of the brand find drunk
kitchen people push back against that so
hard you don't come here and get drunk
yeah yeah they're like so buddy would
this my drunk kitchen girl and like we
have the support of some major
charitable organizations helping us put
in get in touch with good people but I
can't actually say their names or be
like front-facing about their support
because they as a public entity also
can't be affiliated with my jerk kitchen
but I'm like okay sure
whatever I get it you know right yeah so
work is still getting done what it I was
gonna ask
so how was Maggie what's the update
there she's great 16 Sasi has a great
tumblr
Scott she's a feminist she's great
Maggie's great she's uh she's lovely
yeah she's just definitely sixteen sassy
pants and what about your mom do you
keep in touch what happened there yeah
she was homeless for a while but then I
was able to support her so I had to
borrow now I just she's got a place that
she stays that and I try and see her one
again yeah and then you so going back to
college she went to Berkeley mm-hmm
kind of you made a decision that my life
is going to continue on this trajectory
yeah I mean I really just like I guess
honestly before all this YouTube stuff
my number one focus was just job
security money just trying to figure out
how to like do it what were you thinking
in terms of major and things like that
well so I studied I went in for
communications like you know I was like
perfect marketing business sound like
that and then I ended up doing
literature because I felt like if you go
after a pure business degree or a pure
marketing degree you're not gaining
anything to bring to the table
so it seemed like literature or
philosophy or history like you're
actually learning things that you can
put in your brain to like make different
connections to create things you know so
I say literature and then I was like
well that's not gonna be enough I should
study an Asian language because Asian
languages are big and also being an
interpreter being a translator that's
something that's not going to really
disappear so I study Japanese I was able
to like go to Japan like I have been
super blessed like super SuperDuper
blessed all right drop some Japanese
science on us Jenny site language
science that's a rap terminology for
like speak something awesome Mizuho nan
de mas mmm I'm drinking water oh and it
tastes good is that what you just said I
was translating to ie
it tastes good oh yeah and we us can you
compliment my check Dinka Sanwa taught
them all koi that's all I said you're
like super cool I think no you said my
nipples were hard they're not I saw
you're looking down there I was giving
you a video once over if you are looking
at my nipples I was trying to find the
nips
do you know those Japanese people look
at her damn again yeah so you become
away so you you master the Japanese
language I do not why I couldn't say
master I mean like if it just sounded
like I sounded pretty awesome I can like
right now I'm like conversational at
best you know is there like there is
there a little Tokyo here in town there
it's not is there there's a little Tokyo
it's very little it's like a mall okay
so you don't like go there and like hey
I got a practice y'all know not really
because yes of course my job is to be a
youtuber now you know give us right give
us the YouTube subscribe to my channel
so how did you go from from studying and
then becoming a translator to being a
youtuber I was living in New York I had
moved from San Francisco to New York for
the company I was working for I was
doing proofreading at that company which
is like white collar mining you know
it's like I would have one patent
document here in one patent document
here has English this is the other
language and just have to kind of go
through looking for errors major every
sentence was in I mean like anyone even
before languages I didn't speak like
German just like making sure it says
like slaw a and just lot B the folk a
and F of B for fall or whatever yes
Japanese yeah no that was German it's
the German then my older sister Naomi
bought me that laptop the MacBook
it was a white whatever the generation
the first like white MacBook with a
webcam yeah now we're in story territory
this is the one everyone gets you to
tell yep this is it but I've got to hear
it so yeah you dull just for sure for
sure is the white MacBook from my sister
story yep my sister Bobby is the juicy
details that you don't give to like the
journalists that's right okay all right
so I was at her apartment cat sitting
and then I was video chatting with a
friend back home because it was so cool
to have video chat the year was 2011 and
I don't know I used to you know my
friend miss me I was like I miss when
you would like get drunk and cook man
and I was like dude I'll do that for you
right now and she was like feeling loved
so then I was like I'm making a video
so I made her my drunk kitchen you you
you ended the I chat and then you said I
said on so I like ended it put up iMovie
hit like import from camera and then
just recorded like 20 minutes 25 minutes
I'm a lightweight I'm like a to drink
drunk three drink drunk to this day and
then chopped it up on iMovie and then
put it up on YouTube in the sent it to
Hannah I killed which is her name and
then you put it on YouTube public but
why would anyone see it
okay what's our YouTube you legitimately
used YouTube for what I think it was
intended for intended for yeah it was
hey I've got a video and I want you to
see it yep
and this is how I'm gonna do it yep
exactly so like I so I did that and I
sent it to her and she don't put it up
on Facebook and all of her friends and
all my friends I was like this is so
funny share share share I mean it wasn't
even that big of a quote-unquote viral
video like it was like it like maybe got
to like a couple hundred thousand I'm
like seven hundred thousand I actually
don't have any idea but I noticed like
people are commenting I was like where's
episode two this is my new favorite show
or is it so - right and I was like what
are they talking about so then I went
into like the YouTube K hole who was
like oh you were not you were not a
youtube consumer is that what you're
saying you didn't watch other youtubers
it was inspire to be that it YouTube was
not that to you the first time I heard
of epicMealTime was in the comments of
that video okay somebody's like this
[ __ ] is ripping off Epic Meal Time
really yeah they've won an episode - and
then your response was like three weeks
later on a random day I put up another
one and then a month after I mean I have
no idea the periods of time in between
certainly wasn't on the schedule
certainly but if we go back on your
channel my heart oh yeah it's all there
it's always sort by date the first one
is the first one yeah but I've changed
the title added like you know
annotations like stay tubed and like
subscribe and like all that stuff now
and it was originally called my drunk
kitchen but now it's called Madrid
kitchen episode 1 but er you're right
yes so you did 2 more you might get two
and then three was supposed to be the
last one and then I just don't know what
Capel I just didn't stop
I don't know I just was fun it was like
such an outlet and then yeah and then
you know it's like money starts coming
in because you're advertising and then
so I quit my translation job and not
because I was so lucrative obviously not
but then I just got rid of my apartment
cut all my expenses and couch surfed so
I could just use all my money for the
things I needed to put it towards and
then I just lived on couches for a while
until I moved to LA which was when
January 2012 okay crazy crazy change
we're coming up on two years yeah here
yeah I just passed two years March 2013
was the second year oh yeah and the
videos of like super improved and now I
just shot a video recently with two
cameras rolling Halloween pain on your
face mmm-hmm pretty well I think it did
I'm on my side of the face was excellent
I just really liked I don't know it was
more than I was so pleased you know I
feel like we should revisit the graffiti
thing maybe oh we could do that now
alright so let's get into this your
sexuality is a big part of your brain
yeah
talking about nipples homos your are a
heterosexual now a link I'm sorry my
getting the terminology wrong I prefer
the term girl kisser okay seen that on a
t-shirt do you sell that t-shirt I
should should think about it I know so
okay so there was a point at which you
decided to be open about your sexuality
on your channel and I don't remember all
the details of those videos but I did
watch those and I remember you just
really got attached the coming-out
chapter one video right yeah so there
were some chapters in this I still post
chapters one marriage passed I put
coming-out chapter five marriage and I
was like marriage is about partnership
is about trust I just talked about my
personal beliefs in marriage and so I
remember one of the things maybe miss
Kwan paraphrasing here but it was you
said something to the effect of you know
I never really felt the need to come out
and this isn't some big deal that I feel
like I needed to come out and like
confess to you guys it I'm a lesbian
it was more like I kind of feel like
maybe I have a responsibility to do that
so I'll I'll do it
you know maybe them yeah you remember
when Anderson Cooper came out and
everybody like it was it's weird think
it was on Episode two of the mole yeah
you know he hosted that right no way
really the reality show competition
showed the mole he was the host of that
first big gig I had no idea he came out
but no one remembers it his hair was
black at the time and him coming out
often the show was not them all as a
whole no so so as you remember when
Anderson Cooper came out uh you know he
was just like guys it's not like I was
hiding it it's just not like my job
isn't to be like gay news guy it's his
news guy you know what I mean and so
like that's kind of the way I feel about
it
you know sexuality in general it's
changing a little bit as I feel more and
more responsible for the LGBT community
because it's like because I happened to
be gay I am inherently a role model
since role models are so few and far
between because there's nothing odd so
it's like out and like Pride and stuff
like that but like in terms of my
personality I've never felt like I mean
since coming to the crippling
realization that I was gay which was
awful by the way well yeah I want to go
in - totally - I almost want to put a
thumbtack
yeah not a pinion yeah and is it
supposed to be a pin maybe a push push a
pen mm-hmm unfurled paperclip can you
give us the whole backstory just I mean
in any way you want to just in terms of
the this sexual backstory because you
know I am very interested about you you
come into grips with being a role model
and being someone first let's hear it
let's hear the story right yeah yeah
totally I was in college sophomore year
of college
and I was in Japanese class and this
girl behind me you know would just like
compliment on my jacket and I was like
oh yeah thanks and then we became like
best friends
she was straight or you know is straight
she's married has baby now um and I just
realized like three weeks in I was like
oh my god like I have like a crush on
this girl and like given also by the way
like I had boyfriends in high school I
always just attributed you know due to
the circumstances of my life I was like
I must really not be able to fall in
love with people maybe that's like a
weird emotional thing I've got like a
block I must not be able to fall in love
because I've never fallen in love and
like I don't really like any my
boyfriend's I mean they're great friends
and they're really attractive guys like
what's wrong with me what's wrong with
me and I was so so so so confused and
obviously homosexuality was not accepted
in either of my households either mom
you know not even a little bit
my dad's grant my dad's dad my grandpa
is gay or was gay
and so I think that's another big thing
that was like super like a big deal for
my dad did you always know that I was
like nine and then it was like a big
deal but it was like he had like two
wives and like six kids or five kids and
he really you know tried to do it and
then just finally he was like 65 and
he's like guys I'm gay I'm sorry I'm
just gay I'm sorry I had two wives I
tried so hard you know so anyway I just
always thought that I just couldn't fall
in love that sort of thing and I
actually remember spring of my freshman
year
no yeah fall of my sophomore year
praying like you know and I would go to
like Christian campus events and I was
just and I remember praying be like let
me fall in love like let me find
somebody I fall in love with like have
that experience and like feel loved and
then sophomore year spring so fall I you
know prayed for that and wanted to fall
in love and then sophomore year the
first class first day of the first
semester you know in the spring I I met
the girl and then I the girl that
complimented the jacket jacket yeah and
then you know we became like super super
close friends and then you know at that
point I had gay friends for the first
time in my life and they're like you
talk about this girl like constantly and
it was always kind of a joke like I
always joke around I'm like yeah I'm
secretly gay haha
which is not uncommon for a lot of
people NWA so anyway long story short I
was kind of like maybe I have a crush in
ER you know what i'ma nip this in the
bud I'm just gonna tell her and then
she's gonna be like EW gross get away
from me forever and I will never have to
think this thought or have this feeling
ever again I told her and she was like
oh my god I think this is crazy
so I went to a party and that night we
made out and I just remember thinking
like when we were like making out I
remember being like wow this is so easy
and I'm gay yeah but it you know
honestly I had in my entire first
relationship fell in love with the first
time whole thing whole thing got my
heart broken went back to dating guys
immediately after because I was like
well I'm not gay it was just that one
girl I'm not gay I'm not gay I'm not gay
it was a fluke there's no way I'm gay
there's no way I'm gay what was going
through your mind that led to the denial
I really really really wanted a shot at
a happy life and I had been raised to
believe that if I was gay I could never
have a happy normal healthy life so it's
like the last thing I wanted
coming through what I had gone through
in terms of was that mm-hmm
couldn't lead a normal life a happy life
in terms of discrimination in terms of
ostracism in terms of what God thought
of you it's like it's all of it I mean
it's you know mainly just that like when
you're raised in a homophobic household
you're really raised to believe that gay
people are like this other thing and so
I'm like why can't be gay cuz I'm not an
other thing I am I mean I'm still 100%
me it's just you know and so like to
have that thought I just didn't want it
to be true because I felt like if I was
gay it was somehow change who I am
mm-hmm and then obviously you know years
of self-reflection and coming out to
very small groups and all that stuff
like it's not true and that's the thing
I kind of advocate the most to kids who
live all across the country meeting
these kids I'm like you don't have to be
the biggest flaming homo in the whole
world and still feel romantic love for
the person
if you love for you know and I think
that like it also got preached to me in
a very like sexual way like it was about
sex
he's about sex which is of course
affiliated with sin and yada yada yada
yada yada but it's see we're not it's
about love I mean you guys know what
romantic love feels like it doesn't feel
like platonic love the different feeling
mm-hmm people seem to ignore that like
sex is just sex you know baby it's great
but you know it's not love I mean so I
mean you were wrestling with all this
you were trying
you had the girlfriend and then you go
buddy go dating guys hmm you had enough
she was officially your girlfriend so
amongst you a group of friends only
need-to-know basis Oh Barry Barry not
out at all even a little bit wasn't
public so then you go back date a couple
of other guys no didn't work yeah once
you've like fallen in love for the first
time like you know like I just was like
I'm like it was just so bad and you know
I really tried now at this time when
you're struggling through this stuff
your relationship with your mom and dad
respectively is weird these are not real
functional relationships it's not like
well she was emancipated you're
emancipated from from your I saw in
contact I mean like you know she was
like my kid you know but it's but it's
not this thing that is it this okay
there's something that has sort of been
ingrained in you personally that you're
kind of struggling where there is there
this like well I don't want to have to
tell my parents about this it does seem
like the parents thing would be that big
of a deal because now you're not it's
still like beyond that you know though I
think that the the sad truth is a
regardless of how your parents were able
to or were not able to take care of you
there is something inherent that makes
you want your parents love and approval
regardless you want to please them you
dad a hundred percent
you know obviously my mom wasn't able to
really comprehend it it was negative we
don't talk about it and my dad you know
I told him when I was like 23 or you
know just randomly I was like not random
blame I was like hey I just wanted to
like give you a heads up not even that
it was
like I'm going to tell you this now you
know cuz we don't we really don't have a
relationship it was just like I felt
like I should it's more for me I guess
you know and then one of the said he
said was uh how you just just what did
you say you were just like BAM
well I immediately burst into tears just
because I just felt and sunny and again
it's really not about it's like what
they represent you know what I mean um
and it was really really hard and then
it was interesting though because you
know he's the word choice which a lot of
people use he's like if you're going to
choose to do this and I was like dad
like your dad's gay like it's not my
choice who I fell in love with and he
said it is your choice and he said it is
your choice whether or not to fall in
love so that's the sin even if you're a
homosexual it's like cool you're gay
it's a new its genetic I get it
I accept that don't ever act on it don't
ever fall in love with somebody just be
single because that will make God
happier that's the choice in his mind
and I was like that's I mean but you
even had have been crushing on some
level of you obviously you expected it
but to hear it yeah I mean it's just
kind of like you know it was but at that
point like I mean our relationship is so
not a factor in my life at that point it
was almost kind of a relief to hear him
say something so ignorant mmm because it
was like wow that doesn't even hurt like
you could package his stance in his own
words and say it felt like watching any
senator talk about how gay people don't
deserve rights you're just like wow
you're one of those you're one of those
bad people so backing up just a little
bit so you you you date the guys and
then what what kind of when did it
become just totally clearing your mouth
now the end the girl your first
girlfriend said that she's not gay I
don't know I mean like it's hot like I
can't label anybody but she definitely
you know went back to the life that she
felt more comfortable in you know I mean
it's a it's like it's unfortunately such
a huge deal but like microscopically
like sit
on the couch arguing about dishes making
dinner falling asleep doing chores like
life level real life level not a deal at
all
but the way I mean some people like you
get you get looked at on the street like
all that other stuff really bleeds into
some people's hearts the way they're
perceived and for me I've never really
been worried about the outside world
like outside world I get it
I have always just really wanted the
happy inside world like coming home and
like having somebody be there being like
hey you know I made dinner
fYI also I did the laundry it's like
that's all I've ever wanted my whole
life you know what I mean it makes
everything worth it but for some people
who grew up with that I think that
having be you know paranoia I'm like do
you think the waitress is being rude to
us because we're here together mmm bad
stuff some people just can't get past so
how did you find that inner voice after
going back to boyfriend's you were c/o
in the fighting phase at this point um
you know just lots of like laying awake
at night feeling frustrated you know I
would play all these games with myself
would be like walking down the street
and see a guy and see a girl who I would
you know be like okay let's say they're
about regular attractive or just see a
random guys here and oh girl I'm like
quick like who do you want to have sex
with you know I'm like trying to force
an answer that and it's like why don't I
sex with either these people are
strangers by the way we should develop
that greed or not kidding there's a new
show in England called the sex box where
people go into a box have sex and then
they come out and they're interviewed by
a panel of sex experts sex birds yeah
shut up I'm not making this up they
stole our idea before we Hank who you
want to have sex with there's a better
idea yes between the bus your sexbots
it's an app now instead of sex box check
spots
oh we brainstorming that I don't know
you just go back to your story yeah yeah
so I'd like do all these mind games with
a which a lot of people struggling with
their identity sexuality audio de
adieu to try and like trick yourself
into an answer trick yourself out of
being gay bah blah blah and just this
emotional maturity it just comes with
time it comes with like life and you
know I would get drunk at a party and
end up accidentally making out with some
girl or like I'd be at a party I'd be
like okay I'm here with this guy who I
like I'm just gonna sit and talk to this
girl on this couch for like the whole
time and like he and I would leave the
party and like go make out in his car
and I would just be like she was so
great kinda shut up your video with this
guy in the car like focus focus you know
get back to the center so eventually you
just get tired of it and you just you
know start to do the personal work to
kind of undo the knots what was that
moment for you that eventually I'm now
tired of this I can't you know I
couldn't I couldn't pinpoint it was it
in college yeah I mean you know yeah
it's hard to say it's a it's a real
amorphous journey now looking back at it
you know there was no other moment the
significant moments I remember were
kissing her for the first time going
back to dating guys and feeling like
that wasn't working and then just kind
of step by step by step just you know
one day at a time kind of accepting it
you know sometimes I would tell people
oh yeah I'm gay have is a stranger I was
never gonna see again well I'm gay well
just like play with it see how it felt
okay so there wasn't this like okay now
is when I'm going to come out of the
closet and just publicly identify my so
I was like I want to try it on this
person and see what I see how they react
yeah I mean there's a lot there's plenty
of people who I never ever ever ever
told and if they watch YouTube or listen
to your biscuits and then now they know
oh they do oh they do they probably
found out on YouTube before your
biscuits just know your biscuits is like
a real big deal so was there a lot of
chatter in the comments of your videos
before you did you before you made a
definitive announcement none I'm not
honestly like non-factor comedies not
about gay or straight just about comedy
but people in comments have a would have
a way of doing that I mean in my first
video people like she looks like Justin
Bieber does she have but like you know
it's always like does she have a
boyfriend
to shave her girlfriend she's hot she's
not hot it's all the same
stuff yeah you know so yeah and then the
coming out video there was just a lot of
like I had no idea I was like really but
then I'm like well who's to say you know
like I hipsters look gay kinda that's
terrible I shouldn't say that you know
yeah I feel bad though when people talk
to me about their coming-out stories I
feel responsible and I'm like I'm sorry
I it's awful you know I get letters from
kids all the time being like you know I
live in Alabama I live in Nebraska I
will never ever tell anybody
I met a thirty year old woman who
recently heart or sexual came out six
weeks ago married whole thing and I'm
like wow
and then my instant how did you met her
in person yeah just me a fan you bump
into people you know okay my instinct is
still because of the way I was raised
are you sure maybe you're not I mean
like do you really wanna do this is how
is your family you know but yeah now I'm
in worl model for it so you know and I
think this is interesting because
there's there's obviously gay
celebrities who people the gay community
may look at as we want you to speak on
our behalf or but it's so different you
know take gay out for a second and just
talk about the difference between a
traditional celebrity and then a YouTube
celebrity there's obvious a obviously a
much stronger connection between your
fan base totally you know a traditional
celebrity isn't sitting around and
reading their fan mail and feeling
responsible for something yeah but we
know you know being in this position
it's just like your your friend your
fans are your friends and there's a
there's a I've been describing them
lately as kind of your boss right yeah
and there's a sense of obligation
because your performance review exactly
yeah and and then you throw in the fact
that ok well now you are in some sense
as a gay icon and and so you know you
get people can't how are you dealing
with that if people are confessing
things to you people are asking
questions yeah well what what is it like
you said you you're interacting with
people they confess their struggles
with you they write you letters I mean
that has to get heavy it does yeah and I
think that like honestly when I'm
talking with them or reacting you know
I'm really try and like I guess choose
faith instead of fear like you try and
be like the brave version of me and not
let like my own you know fear compromise
that and just be like if they can see me
as someone who's like brave and
confident and comfortable and unabashed
and all that good stuff then like and
that's the person that they look up to
like then I am then there must be some
truth in that like that is that part of
me regardless of like the internal
whirlwind of me being like oh my god but
it's getting easier I mean when it first
started oh my god what I mean what is
that internal whirlwind it's just
basically like I just don't wanna be
like suffer but it's like you have to
choose your suffering right what you're
gonna do is just be in the closet girl
life and be like I'm miserable or are
you gonna go through that really kind of
brutal kind of reaching for something
richer but I think that's all life it's
like do you choose comfort stability or
are you gonna pursue your like deeper
truth like and that's a choice people
make now do you think that do you
respond individually to people or do you
take into account the things that people
are saying to you personally and then
let it change your content because
you're kind of speaking to everyone at
the same time like if people keep asking
me about this maybe I should make a
video to answer this question
collectively or I'm gonna respond to
this person I think that you know it
varies you guys know it's like there's
no like direct set always a hundred
percent system sometimes a comment will
hit home and you're like I'm not talking
about this
sometimes you'll notice a trend and
you're like I'm gonna talk about this
you know it's really just case-by-case
but I would imagine you're hearing
horror stories of people growing up in
the closet and not knowing kids not
knowing what to do with themselves I
mean you're getting those type of
letters right mm-hmm I guess I kind of
feel like something good that's you know
I'm getting those type of letters for a
reason maybe that reason is I can show
them like a happy life you know so it's
like I don't
but hey I don't want to get too freaky
be it is only a portion of the audience
and see they've sent me that letter
because of something already you know
what I mean so it's like maybe the beat
way being a role model is to continue to
do things the way I do them you know
mm-hmm but I do yeah I mean there are
videos that there's like a list of
videos that I really want to do but is
it you know it's like heavier stuff and
it's you know it's you know the ones
like the smaller videos that are more
serious they're always the ones you take
more to heart you know what I mean and
like once you put stuff like that out
there it's out there you know when it
almost is like well you keep it close
well you play it play it close you're
like well maybe someday and I once put
it out there like oh I guess that really
wasn't as big a deal as I thought you
know what type of things I mean
obviously you're not you not you haven't
made those videos yeah but what type of
questions maybe don't give us your
answer as much as what are the questions
I mean like these teens like we
represent like a strong teen audience
right and like like I don't know if it's
I think that there's a real problem with
like I mean frankly I really want to do
a video about self-harm like kind of
just talking about it like taking away
like demonizing it and just like
speaking directly I mean like your
things you could do to like maybe help
yourself out you know I had a girl show
me like her cuts on her arm and she told
me she was like you help me stop doing
this and her mom was with her and her
mom was crying
she's like Jay was like you help me stop
doing this you know stop doing this um
so thank you so do you and we'll wrap up
here in a second but I I think that you
know you've got this responsibility
you've got people asking you these
questions do you think it at some point
it changed from I'm an entertainer to
like okay now I'm responsible you know
because I think you know it's
interesting because I think because of
who you are and the nature of your
content and the fact that you you have
talked about your sexuality in videos
it's it's significantly different than
just two comedians who are making a
bunch of funny videos where we think
about the next video we think about the
next project we're like what thing are
we going to create
that's going to entertain not that we
don't feel a sense of responsibility to
our audience and that kind of thing but
it seems that there's a there's a little
bit more of a it's a little little
weightier with you it does that affect
like what you're gonna work on next
I think it kind of honestly like the
comedy stuff is like obviously more
popular and it's great and it's comedy
and so it's wonderful to be an
entertainer and you know I know grace
gets a lot of intense stuff sent her way
too but grace is a performer she's an
entertainer she's a comedian she studied
it she want to do it her whole life like
that's her thing I think that because I
never pursued entertainment the fact
that there's some residents that can be
more worthwhile in a different way
because comedy is worthwhile but
worthwhile in a different way
makes it more rewarding for me
personally because I mean I love making
people laugh but I also want to make
things better do and whatever way again
I think for you know just to wrap up I
and at the risk of kind of taking them
couples a step backwards I'm going to
say nipples one more time I think maybe
just this is reacting a question and
reach writing some ground but people who
would say there's certain people who may
listen to our conversation here and
they'll say you know that hand I see you
know she had a screwed up past that's
actually why she's gay yeah I know it's
so and like look you're not like oh okay
but you know who else is gay people that
come from quote-unquote perfect
household you know else's gay black
people white people ancient people you
know penguins dolphins like I get it but
like there are people that it's it's
it's I get I get really frustrated when
people bring that up because it's a so
obvious be so irrelevant because there's
so much more evidence saying the
opposite
but people like I figured you out you
came from a broken home and that's why
your you feel the need to be homosexual
and it's like you know a lot of people
come from broken homes a lot of people
come from healthy homes and a lot of
people are gay and a lot of people are
straight it
you know it's just frustrating well
Hannah I will say this I am very glad
that you wiped all of the makeup that we
put on your face off before we had this
conversation taking a different oh my
god it you know what it's so funny I've
just I totally forgot I'm talking to
half field use half Wolfman okay we need
you to sign the table right grab the
sharpie where is that brother okay I
have any makeup left over we got music
sure I can find it I can find the sharp
half Chiefs fan half Cardinals fan but
seriously thanks so much for sharing as
much as you did and for allowing us to
have this conversation yeah and this I
feel honored you're very sweet
also I will be editing this episode of
uh your biscuits they're looking at me
so seriously right now you guys came to
talk no absolutely no we're thinking she
doesn't know that there's no editing at
all right yeah okay yeah it's a podcast
it just goes and that was our
conversation with Hannah Hart want to
thank Hannah ferb he's coming and being
real with an air biscuit get the table
of dim lighting she she opened up
Childers a real story yeah he tells it
you ever heard before like it was a
privilege that she decided to share to
that extent and we were able to gain an
understanding of who she is and where
she came from it thinks that she had to
deal with with her parents and
everything you know that I think that
kind of unpacking her mom's story was
something that maybe at first she didn't
know we that we wanted to go there that
was a type of thing we want to talk
about on the podcast once we stopped
recording Hannah told us that she didn't
want to seem like she was being evasive
and talking about her mom and her mom's
illness that it was just getting a feel
for where the podcast was going but that
once that was something that you know I
don't know how how far to push on things
like that but I'm glad that she was
comfortable sharing
that part of her life and having to deal
with her mom's illness and continuing to
deal with it to this day so the fact
that she was comfortable sharing that
too is you know I'm I'm just I love this
show I love doing this I'm not I feel
like we crafted this type of
conversation for us this is these the
type of conversations that we want to
have with people but I'm glad that you
out there in the listening world of the
internet enjoy it yeah because I would
say that the way I would characterize
this show so far is this I think it's a
pretty selfish endeavor honestly because
typically what we do is we just try to
entertain people I mean you know not
that we aren't when we do good mythical
morning when we do another video that we
aren't sitting down and trying to unpack
something or but it's almost always for
purely for entertainment purposes and
with very little idea as to where this
whole thing was gonna go and what your
bummy first what we call the ear
biscuits we didn't really know what it
was gonna be with like let's just sit
down and talk to some people that we
know from the internet maybe some people
that we don't know from the internet and
ask them the questions that we actually
legitimately have for them and just have
an interesting conversation without
trying to be entertaining or trying to
be funny but I have to say when I when I
go back and I listen to these it's
hitting me I'm like I I am being
entertained by this I am enjoying these
conversations because these people that
we're talking to aren't interesting you
know that they've got that everyone has
this story and when you could begin to
put the story together with a person
that you know publicly there's
everything you learn a lot and you know
it's it's challenging in a lot of ways
and you know I think that happened some
tonight so thanks to those of you who
are listening to this on a weekly basis
though the template is set this is what
we're gonna do yeah every week you're
sharing it you're letting people know
about it we obviously appreciate that
and we see the comments on Twitter
Facebook SoundCloud we see all those
comments and we appreciate the feedback
thanks for watching with your ears
we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Music]